bien sûr en pensant très fort à la
famille de ce policier camille chaise
est avec nous merci d'être là je camille
donc porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
dans cette opération parce qu'on a on a
on n'a pas bien compris c'est s'est
passé c'est à la base d'une opération de
lutte contre les stupéfiants ou alors à
la base c'est ces policiers ils étaient
engagés sur une autre opération
judiciaire dans une autre ville à
carpentras il était de retour dans leur
ville d'origine avignon et là il ya eu
un appel 17 à la salle de commandement
comme on dit dans notre jargon et ils
ont été détournés avant de revenir à
leur point de base et finir leur service
ils ont été détournés parce qu'ils
avaient comme on dit dans notre jargon
des fauteurs de trouble donc des gens
qui mettait le bazar à un endroit donc
ils se rendent sur place ils étaient ils
étaient plusieurs équipages
la situation est plutôt calme je vois
qu'ils étaient cinq ou six policiers ce
qui est assez nombreux pour ce type
d'intervention là il n'y a pas forcément
de tapas jour ou de chahut par contre il
remarque une transaction de stupéfiants
en cours une toxicomane qui est en train
d'acheter d'acheter de la drogue et donc
ils vont procéder au contrôle de cette
femme et de deux autres personnes
et c'est là qu'un des deux individus
tire tire sur notre policier qui tombe à
terre qui est qui meurent quasi
immédiatement
j'en ai la chair de poule en vous
parlant mais voilà ce soir c'est tout le
ministère de l'intérieur qui endeuille
toute la france qui ont de rien je vous
le dis on a eu on a entendu des
témoignages de gens qui disaient qu'il
voyait des collègues de ce policier qui
était devant lui et il est temps sont
ils le voyaient voilà partir c'est vrai
que ça a été traumatisant pour tout le
monde hier soir c'était c'était
l'émotion la douleur mais en fait ce
matin et toute la journée c'est pareil
en fait c'est des choses qui passent pas
de la peine pour les proches pour la
famille mais aussi une grande
détermination on sait qu'on est le
pilier de la république on se bat pour
que les gens vivent en sécurité et on
sait qu'on va continuer donc une grande
une grande douleur une grande peine mais
aussi une très grande détermination pour
pour continuer tout ça dans quel état
ils sont les autres policiers qui sont
intervenus avec lui et qui ont vécu ce
drame alors les plus proches c'est
catastrophique 1 vous avez vu votre
collègue avec qui c'est votre coéquipier
a faim c'est un peu comme dans les films
vous la suivez vous vivez tout le temps
et vous vivez des moments forts avec
cette personne vous avez des souvenirs
communs donc pour eux c'est cesser c'est
l'horreur absolue tout simplement
donc voilà c'est ils vont mettre des
années à se remettre et je pense qu'on
s'en remet jamais c'est quelque chose
qui va rester toute leur vie
profondément ancrée entre eux en eux et
toute la police on pense tout ça voilà
on a tous quelqu'un qui connaît c'est
quelqu'un qui le connaissaient donc
c'est pour ça quand on dit là la famille
ou la maison police nationale la maison
ministère de l'intérieur s'est pas qu'un
mot c'est ça on voit là on connaît tous
quelqu'un qui le connaissaient qui était
proche et voilà ce policier il était
expérimenté il avait commencé comme
beaucoup de policiers dans le notamment
dans le val-de-marne en banlieue
parisienne c'est souvent ça les débuts
de carrière en région parisienne avant
de pouvoir rejoindre dès qu'on estime
soit plus clément soit avec moins de
délinquance mais on voit qu'en fait le
danger pour un policier ça peut être à
tous les coins de rue même j'allais dire
là c'était une intervention vraiment
quotidienne ça une intervention un appel
17 un appel police secours c'est
vraiment une attestation du quotidien
c'est pas une intervention on se dit ils
risquent d'avoir un drame c'est une
intervention voilà qui est assez
courante assez banal j'ai envie de dire
et qui se termine par un drame donc
c'est aussi un match encore pire bien
sûr mais après dans notre métier on sait
qu'il n'ya pas d'intervention anodine on
le sait ça peut être un refus
d'obtempérer sur la route voilà on sait
que le danger il est partout dans nos
métiers
après voilà je sois milieu ans et pour
sa famille qui le ministre de
l'intérieur a eu sa famille au téléphone
oui dans cette voie là il appelle la
famille
par deux fois au commissariat hier soir
ce matin encore et pas pour amener la
presse et je pense qu'il a fait vraiment
avec avec une grande sincérité et
beaucoup d'émotion parce que c'est des
moments faut être avec nos collègues de
terrain qui sont qui sont allées au
commissariat là bas on imagine
l'ambiance c'est quoi ces on se dit on a
envie de tout arrêter où on se dit non
on a envie au contraire d'essayer de
retrouver ce couple n'a pas encore été
interpellé
la vérité c'est que c'est que ce deuil
chacun le vit aussi différemment
il y en a qui sont dans la colère et
s'est totalement compréhensible y en a
qui sont au contraire dans le
recueillement il y en a qui pense à la
famille qui est cherche plein de
solutions sur comment s'occuper des
enfants de sa femme et cetera il y en a
qui pensent aux commémorations il y en a
enfin voilà chacun le vit différemment
en tout cas nous tous les policiers tous
les gendarmes tous les sapeurs pompiers
de france je crois tu l'as dit toute la
population française on pense voilà on
pensa à nos policiers david aujourd'hui
le coupable n'a toujours pas été
interpellé donc l enquête avance will
enquête avance on a une cinquantaine
d'enquêteurs spécialisés de la police
judiciaire certains sont venus de paris
donne d'autres villes du sud qui sont
présents dans ces cas là on a tout un
panel d'investigation ça peut être la
vidéoprotection même si on n'avait pas
pile poil dans cette rue on sait qu'il y
en a au tour ça peut être des enquêtes
de voisinage fin on a on a un panel
d'outils quand même important c'est en
cours ça avance bien
voilà ce qu'on peut pas voilà non plus
empêché l'enquète d'avancé doute et c
est tout ce qui vient perturber
l'enquète s'est jamais donc voilà sachez
que les enquêteurs de la police
judiciaire sont extrêmement mobilisés
que ça avance et qu'on espère que le ou
les individus sont rapidement
interpellés et jugés parce que c'est le
seul objectif aussi le ça je dis pas que
ça serve de leçon parce que c'est on en
n'est même pas là mais que ce soit
symbolique aussi parce que on doit ça
notre policier qui est juste là dans la
foi vous étiez venu nous voir il ya une
dizaine de jours je vous avais posé la
question est ce qu'on a encore des
jeunes qui ont envie de devenir policier
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé hier
quand on voit ce qui se passe
actuellement est ce qu'on se dit pas ce
que les policiers je sais qu'ils sont
ils gagnent pas des salaires mirobolants
il faut
12 heures est ce que il ya encore c'est
cette envie de devenir policier
quand on voit en plus des événements
comme ceux-là ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est un métier d'engagement donc une sa
vie on donne sa vie un engagement qui
est la sécurité des autres donc il faut
avoir ça en soit faut sentir ça dans ses
tripes
si on n'a pas envie d'être ainsi au
service du public et donner de son temps
de sa vie de sa vie familiale aussi
parce que le travail de policier
souvent on travaille de nuit on a des
horaires particuliers donc c'est sûr que
si on n'a pas ça en soit c'est c'est pas
un métier qu'il faut embrasser après on
a plein de jeunes qui on vit aussi qui
qui sont fascinés par exemple parle
enquête par le renseignement par par
l'intervention aussi donc si on a
beaucoup de volontaires on a une
campagne qui s'ouvre bientôt les
inscriptions sont bientôt ouverte
on espère qu'ils seront nombreux et et
on a besoin de tous ces jeunes parce que
tout seul on n'y arrivera pas il faut
aussi des jeunes qui s'engagent avec
nous qui viennent qui viennent renforcer
les commissariats terrain la police
judiciaire les services de renseignement
je vais vous dire moi j'ai des amis qui
sont aussi dans la police et dans la
voix je discute avec eux et ils me
disaient nous parfois c'est vrai que
quand on va sur une intervention
on se dit on et peut considérer il se
trouve peu considérée par par l'état ils
gagnent des salaires qui sont voilà qui
sont comme j'ai dis pas du tout
mirobolants ils lisent un moment
pourquoi aller risquer notre vie sur des
interventions et ils me disent tu sais
parfois même on peut fermer les yeux sur
certaines choses c'est pas c'est pas
voilà ils disent pas c'est vrai qu'à un
moment on va le facteur risque est
tellement important
le jeu n'en vaut pas la chandelle c'est
un truc qui vont vers vous aussi oui
c'est un truc c'est un truc qui nous
revient qu'on entend à après je pense
que le moteur pour tous les policiers
les gendarmes de terrain c'est se dire
que si nous on le fait pas personne ne
le fera on est vraiment le dernier
rempart une fois de plus de la
république on est là avant tout pour
pour les petites gens qui si la police
n'était pas la vivre est dans
l'insécurité absolue c'est ça notre
raison d'être c'est ça qui me motive
tous les jours et qui nous fait aller
parfois avec des risques parfois très
importants sur des interventions alors
il ya eu ce tragique événement hier le
23 avril attentats au commissariat
commissariat de rambouillet stéphanie
dont on a parlé ici est ce qu'une
psychose qui commence à s'installer dans
les commissariats ou autour des des
forces de police on peut pas dire qu'il
ya une psychose ces deux événements qui
sont qui sont totalement différent sur
le terrorisme on sait qu'on est la cible
dans la propagande de l'état islamique
ou de dèche etc
on sait que plusieurs fois il a été
publié attaquez-vous à des militaires
français des policiers français on sait
qu'on est la cible du terrorisme
là c'est tout autre chose c'est une
intervention du quotidien on sait qu'on
on a une politique très forte
anti-stupéfiants actuellement on sait
qu'on gêne les dealers et c'est pour ça
que je commençais en vous disant
beaucoup de douleur beaucoup d'émotion
mais aussi de la détermination parce qu
on lâchera pas on continuera partout sur
le terrain à mener cette lutte parce que
finalement on voit bien que c'est
vraiment le début de tous les tournois
la démotivation je vais pas vous mentir
elle est aussi dans l'esprit des gens
mais les policiers ils sont engagés
et en même temps et 10 j'en ai marre je
vais tout arrêter mais le lendemain
matin ils sont là ils sont présents et
il continue parce qu'il voit bien qu'il
faut pas laisser ces pauvres gens dans
l'insécurité et avec des quartiers qui
tombe à la main des dealers moi ce que
je me dis aussi c'est qu'on se trompe
pas de combat
certains des fois peuvent avoir sur les
stupéfiants un discours disons
d'acceptation disant c'est pas très
grave non c'est grave parce que ça
génère du trafic divers de l'économie
souterraine du trafic d'armes la
circulation illégale d'armes et ça nous
mène à ce type de drame là aujourd'hui
c'est un policier tué mais par le passé
on a eu des enfants qui ont été tués
dans des règlements de comptes donc
voilà c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui
que c'est nous qui sommes touchés alors
on le vit avec j'allais dire encore plus
d'intensité mais c'est ça la réalité
dans certains quartiers et donc je pense
qu'on se trompe pas en luttant fermement
avec cette politique anti drogue
oui j'ai regardé ce qui est effrayant la
vigne on sait que c'est un dealer
quelqu'un qui vend des produits
stupéfiants la police arrive
ils tirent pour tuer un policier est ce
que vous avez peur justement comme vous
luttez beaucoup contre la drogue que
certains dealers ça remet directement et
tire maintenant sur des policiers ce
qu'elle disait
mais sur les perquisitions c'est très
très fréquent qu'on trouve des désarment
heures ma feu et d'autres types d'armes
ils ont des seins pour sécuriser leur
business aussi tout simplement et par
contre ils osent les utiliser contre les
forces de l'ordre mais peut-être at-il
même pas réfléchi à son geste je ne sais
pas ce qui a pu passer dans la tête de
cette personne mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que les trafics d'armes et les trafics
de stupéfiants s'est complètement
imbriqués aujourd'hui et d'autres
trafics d'économie souterraine diverses
alors bien au delà il ya eu des
accusations de racisme sur des policiers
en certains accusent aussi la police
d'être violent qu'il s'agit des gilets
jaunes éborgné ou d'autres bavure qui
ont fait l'actualité sont où ceux ci
voient la stigmatiser la policière et le
journal libération qui faisait sa une
sur un jeune homme gravement blessé par
un tir de l bd lors d'une opération de
la bac en février 2020 vous avez vous
l'avez vu cette unis hier en point oui
je l'avais vu hier avant même
l'assassinât de notre collègue
qu'est ce que vous a provoqué comme vos
réactions moi là-dessus j'aurais de
réaction la première c'est que je crois
profondément à la liberté de la presse
chaque média sa ligne éditoriale c'est
moi je suis pour la pluralité des
opinions et on sait que que que
libération s'est se fait fort de
défendre les personnes blessés mutilés
par les armes donc voilà ils sont dans
leurs lignes éditoriales je dis pas que
je suis d'accord mais je dis que c'est
la démocratie et qui peuvent le faire
après la deuxième chose que ça me
suscitant sur le fond c'est oui un tir
de mg bid et le tir de l bd le lanceur
de balles de défense c'est une arme dont
est dotée la doter la police et les
armes ça blesse les armes c'est fait
pour blesser c'est fou c'est pour tuer
et quand on les utilise et qu'on n'a pas
d'autre choix que de le faire et on le
fait dans un nuage légitime et
proportionné des choses donc voilà c'est
leur choix et san pedro les
constitutions aussi des faits passés
haut la vue oui mais ils ont démontré en
fait que le jeune homme ne représentait
aucun danger pour les forces de l'ordre
au moment où il
tirez dessus vous l'avez vu sa tronche
ça c'est l'heure c'est leur posture
leurs postures médiatiques
après il ya des enquêtes tout ça il ya
des enquêtes de la police des polices
des fois des enquêtes judiciaires sous
le contrôle des magistrats et c'est à la
justice de dire au final 6 et
proportionnée si c'est légitime mais je
peux vous dire que si ça ne l'est pas
les policiers ont des sanctions des
révocations ont des peines deux fois
devant les tribunaux des tribunaux tout
cela ça se fait pas au petit bonheur
comme ça enfin derrière nous aussi on
respecte des règles on respecte des lois
des règlements et nous aussi on est
extrêmement contrôlée est jugée parfois
pour pour des choses graves qui ont pu
être connu
willy bernard motté à vous dire que non
si je voulais dire c'est qu'il y avait
aussi un problème de justice parce que
en fait on parle de jugement bon les
condamnations elles se font pas et moi
je sais pas ce que les policiers me le
disent dans la rue il nous paraît qu'ils
nous voient à la télévision et tout ça
edit c'est terrible tout ce qui arrive
évidemment on condamne tout ce qui
arrive à la violence c'est inadmissible
mais quoi qu'il en soit les peines ne
sont pas effectués donc du coup ils en
ont ras le bol de retourner le branleur
du coin qui a fait ceci ou cela et
qu'après il ressort de jours apprend les
insultes en plus moi je comprends leur
détresse les mecs au bout d'un moment
ils se sentent pas soutenus
la police ne se sent pas soutenu et je
comprends que j'en ai ras-le-bol
franchement alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ces cas là qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire il a raison là dessus c'est un
sentiment que ne que nos policiers
ressentent effectivement beaucoup après
les policiers disent aussi et ils ont
raison je pense quand on voit le
fonctionnement des tribunaux le manque
de moyens des tribunaux souvent ils sont
maison passée de juge pas assez
personnel pour faire fonctionner tous à
passer des deux fois de place pour
mettre les personnes en prison même si
tout ne doit toutes les personnes ne
doivent pas forcément aller en prison
mais c'est aussi il faut se mettre à la
place aussi des de la justice qui
parfois est vraiment en manque de moyens
et moi je suis pas de ceux qui tombent à
hara kiri sur la justice on est vraiment
une chaîne on a ce sentiment c'est vrai
mais je pense aussi que la justice
mangou de beaucoup de moyens
benjamin ou non mais c'est vrai qu'on ya
fait un mois qu'il ya deux doigts de
discourir on dit faut plus de sécurité
faux et ce qui est normal et puis d'un
autre côté il ya ces images là et qui en
fait vos brouille donc je vois pas
comment vous pouvez gérer à la fois le
fait de dire voilà il faut plus de
sécurité et en même temps vous vous
luttez contre les opérations alors on
sait pas ce qu'ils voient dans ce cas
précis forcément l'image de la police
elle est un petit peu écornée alors
qu'on est on dit ou 6 et cyril da déjà
dix vingt fois on sait que 99% des
policiers où ils sont ni
s'il n'ya ni ni violent mais c'est
compliqué de gérer les deux c'est
compliqué de gérer les deux mais je
pense qu'il faut le faire il faut être
extrêmement républicain dans tout ce
qu'on fait je pense que les faits de
violences illégitimes doivent être
dénoncées de racisme ou de manquements
déontologiques faut être extrêmement
ferme là dessus et dire que c'est pas
acceptable en république parce qu'il
faut que les gens aient confiance dans
la police et quand il ya des choses non
déontologique qui se passe cette
confiance elle est rompue et c'est
extrêmement grave et en même temps il
faut clairement dire que comme on l'a
déjà dit ici à 99,9 pour cent
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe et
les policiers sont des gens extrêmement
courageux et qui une fois de plus
risquent leur vie et paie un tribut
extrêmement lourd pour défendre notre
pays
camille vous avez eu les collègues du
policier qui a été tué ou les aveo
sauver non moi je les connais pas et
j'aimerais les les importuner en leur
téléphonant d'accord le le ministre les
a vus forcément là hier c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on se met à leur place on
dit compliqué de retourner au travail
compliqué de retourner sur des
interventions
quand on a vécu un tel drame la veille
ils ont invité travail aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas je pense qu'ils se sont
retrouvés
parce qu'on en a envie dans ces
moments-là d'être avec des proches
pensent qu'ils se sont retrouvés
je veux pas être pessimiste mais
certains peut-être prendront jamais
leurs services alignons de le
demanderont peut-être leur mutation
peut-être que certains sont en arrêt
maladie fin après une fois de plus comme
je le disais tout à l'heure chacun vit
son deuil aussi et son traumatisme parce
que ça en est un pour les proches
différemment donc voila moi moi moi je
les ai eus au téléphone ces policiers 19
mai prochain à paris vous aviez assisté
par dont il ya une marche il ya une
marche qui va être fait probablement je
ne sais pas si ça vient de tomber
l'intersyndicale de la police annoncé
jeudi soir l'organisation d'une marche
des policiers quand il ya des
intersyndicales nous on a dit syndicats
dans la police c'est beaucoup d'habitude
ils sont plutôt à ce que régler entre
eux quand ils d un fer 5 mal c'est
vraiment qu'il ya un moment fort et
c'est des moments où il faut être tous
unis dans le passé comme il se doit
leurs valets que je suis je suis pas
certaine je suis pas sûr que ce soit sa
place en tout cas moi ce que j'entends
de tous les syndicats de police et
qu'ils trouvent que leur ministre et
avec eux et ça c'est ça c'est bien